[Música]
vamos a las noticias desde la economía
aquí en directo américa edición nocturna
y para ello saludo a mi compañero jorge
hurtado jorge buenas noches para usted
para noches angela bueno vamos a empezar
en américa latina' en argentina ya se
presentó el dato de la inflación
cuéntenos ha sido pero los precios al
consumidor se dispararon ahí el
78,5 por ciento interanual es la mayor
tasa registrada en 30 años el instituto
nacional de estadísticas y censos
reportó que el índice de inflación fue
en agosto del 7% en comparación con
julio deseando una mínima desaceleración
con respecto a la tasa del 7,4 por
ciento mostrado en el séptimo mes del
año esta magnitud de alza interanual es
la más alta desde diciembre de 1940 91
cuando argentina intentaba dejar atrás
la hiperinflación que vivió entre el 89
y el año 90 esta leve desaceleración de
los precios de agosto en comparación con
julio también coincidió con la llegada
de sergio massa como nuevo ministro de
economía de argentina y sus primeras
medidas en este rubro varios sondeos
prevén que la inflación será este año
del 95 por ciento anual y que al menos
hasta febrero del próximo año la tasa
mensual no será menor al 5 5 % vamos a
pasar a eeuu las miradas están puestas
sobre las negociaciones entre
ferroviarios y sindicatos sé que podrían
terminar en un paro este viernes de
concretarse esa huelga sería de la más
grande en 30 años entra que es una de
las ferroviarias más grandes de ese país
canceló todos los trenes de larga
distancia a partir de este jueves según
la empresa está realizando ajustes
graduales ya que un paro la bola laboral
podría perjudicar a los servicios
ferroviarios de pasajeros en las rutas
en las que operan en vías que son
propiedad de los ferrocarriles de carga
y que son mantenidas por estos mismos la
posible huelga paralizaría una amplia
gama de mercancías transportadas por
ferrocarril que van desde alimentos
hasta metales y piezas de automóviles
además de provocar el caos en los
desplazamientos de miles de viajeros uno
de los sindicatos rechazó un acuerdo
tentativo con los mayores ferrocarriles
de carga de eeuu mientras que 22
ratificaron los acuerdos y otros tres
permanecieron en la mesa de negociación
a pocos días que termine este plazo en
otras noticias e también de eeuu el
presidente de joe biden hizo un anuncio
de 900 millones de dólares así ese ese
plan es precisamente en infraestructura
para construir cargadores de vehículos
eléctricos esto como parte de una
legislación sobre infraestructuras
aprobada en 2021 que proporcionará 5 mil
millones de dólares en cinco años para
ayudar a los estados a crear una red de
estaciones de carga de vehículos
eléctricos el anuncio lo hizo durante la
visita el presidente joe biden al salón
del automóvil de detroit según esta
nueva ley los vehículos eléctricos
tienen que ser fabricados en eeuu para
poder optar a un crédito fiscal federal
de hasta 7 mil 500 dólares las baterías
y los minerales de las baterías también
producir o reciclar en el en el
continente este primer desembolso
ayudará a poner cargadores eléctricos en
53 mil millas del sistema nacional de
carreteras que abarca 35 estados y vamos
a seguir hablando de energía pero en
europa francia ya anunció que va a
limitar el aumento de precios de la
electricidad y del gas los aumentos
quedarán en un 15% el año próximo según
lo anunció la primera ministra elizabeth
voy a la medida se da en plena crisis
energética europea por la guerra en
ucrania los topes costarán a francia 16
mil millones de dólares y evitarán que
las facturas de los hogares se dupliquen
también seguirán los cheques de 200
euros para los más pobres unos 12
millones de hogares se beneficiarán de
esta medida hoy la unión europea
presentó los planes para recaudar más de
140 mil millones de dólares de las
empresas energéticas para ayudar a
proteger a los hogares y las empresas de
esta subida de presión europea dice que
las empresas energéticas están
recibiendo sobre ganancias debido a esta
crisis y bueno van a tratar de imponer
un impuesto a ellas y en reino unido-
también se están enfrentando el aumento
de los precios la inflación británica
cayó levemente en agosto pero se
mantiene cerca del máximo de 40 años del
mes anterior el índice de precios al
consumo se desaceleró hasta el 9,9 por
ciento anual en agosto tras acelerarse
hasta el 10,1 por ciento en julio según
la oficina de estadísticas nacionales el
mes pasado el banco de inglaterra subió
su tipo de interés principal en 0,5
puntos porcentuales hasta 1 75% es la
mayor subida desde 1995 con el fin de
frenar esta inflación al alza la primera
ministra británica recién nombrada
listos anunció la semana pasada la
congelación durante dos años de los
precios de la energía en ese en esa
nación en un intento de reducir
precisamente el costo de vida ordenó
agradecimiento para ustedes vamos a una
pequeña pausa y ya regresamos con el
debate de france 24